let's talk about John Jones he just got
a DUI with a gun charge all this stuff
but my understanding is that he was
actually sitting in the car asleep right
he wasn't actually driving I don't think
he was driving at the time but Sally
Hughes city I don't think you're
sleeping because they said they said the
reason that the officers respondent was
because there was a gun shot which is
apparently his gun because there was
like I apparently an empty casing or
something found so I don't think he shot
in the air but the part that was the
most crazy to me is he says something
like he was intending to try again later
like why would you tell them that like
this make up just some kind of lie he
said I was driving and I'm intending on
driving more later and it's like oh for
God's sakes just tell them like you know
you came in here just to listen to the
radio or I don't know make up some type
of lie but you know your vehicle is not
actually moving so you could probably if
you weren't idiot you could probably
argue that one away in court somehow I'm
guessing I don't know yeah the I think
it was you they just said hey why don't
you just hire your buddy right and just
be your driver for you for like 50k a
year and and just stay out of trouble I
said that the last two times I mean this
is it this is his third DUI this is not
this is not time number one is this time
time number three it's like and you know
he obviously has other people with the
best interested in whether it's his
coach his manager people who sponsor him
Dana White the UFC president I'm you
know if Jeff even rolled John Jones out
three times a year that's can be a lot
better than if you can't for a year and
a half which dude I mean three duis I
think that I'm pretty sure that's
mandatory jail time in most states plus
the add on the fact that he had a loaded
weapon and it was fired and he had weed
and if the man do the drugs he's
probably born there I'm guessing so yeah
I mean how they haven't found it I
actually just did a live stream on this
the other day I had this dear you won't
hear my theory pump if I want to hear it
okay I have this theory and I I'm in the
process of putting it all together
actually knew who kind of inspired me I
started I talked to a couple times
I've listened to him on your show and I
somehow connected with him on Twitter
with sampar oh yeah yeah he's grant him
on the hustle maybe maybe yeah maybe two
or three weeks ago you had him on and
and then I listened to that and then
somehow we connected through Twitter and
yeah we got a call he kind of like I've
had this idea about showing him a head
for a while and he kind of pushed push
me a little further into it but but the
idea is that success is a skill and you
have all these mental characteristics
that are necessary to be to be
successful in something that being said
different things take different sets
right and the more of these since I've
like 500 categories the more they set
you could put together the better off
you mean so for example being an athlete
especially being a cage fighter
something where there's a high level
risk you need to be really low anxiety
for exaggerate this is a word about was
one trait of the many traits right but
if you're all worried oh my god this guy
could kick me or you could punch me if
you choke me oh my god there's 20,000
people watching me oh my god I could get
knocked out right there's all these
things you were say if you're high
anxiety you're probably not gonna have a
high level of success so John Jones is
really arrogant low anxiety those type
of things are great attributes to have
in mixed martial arts and you know that
I can't get in trouble no one can hurt
me type of mentality great it's great
that's great you want it there and so
then I you know the argument I'm making
is like well number one you should you
should work on your weakness but number
two especially if you're John Jones and
you know you have these weaknesses and I
use the SIP one for myself listen bro if
there's ice cream and cake and cookies
you're on I'm gonna eat it so when I'm
dieting for a fight my wife is not
allowed to buy it we don't we do not
have it in the house ho because I will
eat it I know I'm weak like that so it's
like John Jones you know you like to
drink and you know you like to drive put
some roadblocks in your way before it
because when it's 3 a.m. in the club and
you're drunk and the cars out there you
get the key you're gonna go drive your
you know yourself you know you're gonna
do that you don't hire yourself a driver
have a couple friends around they're a
little responsible and put roadblocks in
your way so you can't make these dumbass
decisions over and over and over again
which are in fact ruining your life yeah
it's pretty crazy because I think
everyone knows kind of what their
weaknesses are some people want to admit
it some people don't but if you are
willing to admit it to yourself that you
can put those roadblocks in place and
kind of prevent the issues from
resurfacing over and over again yeah
yeah I mean that's that's a huge one so
yeah my I need to put this in the fryer
I have a couple different like
psychology theories that I don't believe
have been written about too much and
this is one of them and so you know not
like another example would be well
you're gonna be a husband soon right you
got you're engaged in you yes I did not
married right okay so like as a husband
and then eventually if you're gonna be a
father
you know for example empathy is like a
gigantic quality to be able to have but
as an athlete dude the more empathetic
you are though it's gonna be it's gonna
negatively affect your career so there's
these certain qualities that are like
okay if you're gonna be a good husband a
father this set of qualities is really
really really really important if you're
gonna be an athlete this is really
important if you me a businessman this
is important if you're an entrepreneur
right because entrepreneurs are
different than employees so employees
are gonna need a different skill set
that an entrepreneur is and so the idea
is that you know you got to mix and
match your mental qualities and then you
know eventually I think most people
would probably like to be diverse enough
to have success in multiple areas like
you know I got to assume even the guys
making billions of dollars but have just
terrible personal lives I can't say this
for sure but man part of that part of
them part of them has to be like
miserable because they can't keep a good
relationship they they're distant from
their kids right or whatever because
they have they probably these really
great qualities that allowed them to
make a billion dollars and those also
probably sabotage them in their personal
life so understanding when to use what
quality where yeah I think it's super
super important I actually just saw tree
surfaced a while ago somebody asked on
Korra what separated you know the Elon
Musk's the Jeff Bezos etc from other
business leaders and Elon Musk's ex-wife
went on and answered and she basically
was like it's obsession but you really
have to be up
best with being great at what you're
doing and solving the problem and
thinking about in 24/7 that also makes
you horrible at other aspects of your
life yeah yeah and that's where it's
like for me I mean that I guess that
would probably my number one issue and I
try to do a good job of it but but being
aware that it is your personality type
and then that can't be a problem and I
always joked with my wife we're not
always joking because sometimes she gets
annoyed with me but like when I was a
high school kid or college kid I was
obsessed with being good at wrestling
and the fact I didn't want to really go
out and party and I was just worried
about being good like everyone saw this
that's freaking awesome like and you
know you get a pat on the back for it
then if you're 35 and you know you just
want to be obsessive about your work and
your wife wants to go socialize with
whoever or you know people see you as
being like weird like why can't that guy
go socially a little mother effer
I just want to be good at what I want to
do but at some point that becomes
unacceptable it's weird it's all it's
all priorities right I always tell
people that some of my favorite advice
is like you hear these you know somewhat
dumb simple statements like you know the
five people you hang out with the
mostess who you become show me your
circle and I'll show you kind of how
successful you will be all these things
but it's true right it really is true
yeah and I think that the other thing is
you're getting judged by people who
don't understand that right the people
who think it's a negative thing they
don't understand kind of the benefits of
it the people who do understand it
they're like well duh of course you're
going to want to focus on what you're
doing and be obsessive about it etc yeah
well so yeah I mean but that's oh I do I
see I definitely see my wife's point and
I think there's a balance to it so it's
like you know expect especially with
especially my kids you know I can't I
can't imagine not giving them attention
so they're like you know I said two side
points of time to give my kids lots of
attention and then you know other people
maybe maybe not nearly as much as I
should or whatever but I try to do my
best